this is sandman being made for people
who love sandman by people who love
sandman we're getting into all the
challenges and behind the scenes visions
of everything that brought this
incredible series to the silver screen
i'm here at shepparton studios and i'm
getting to see what happens when you
bring dreams to life number one tom
sturridge who plays dream was basically
naked for the entirety of the first
episode the way he was first introduced
to his fellow castmates was naked
climbing into a glass sphere and because
of the way the sphere was designed they
couldn't open it super easily so he
would be in there by himself for hours
at a time one aspect he loved about that
though was how that really helped him
get into character in that silence you
can only ever really believe yourself to
be a character number two speaking of
getting into character one thing tom
really struggled with was being
introduced as a protagonist who doesn't
speak or even move much for that matter
it was incredibly important to me to
somehow articulate this otherworldliness
he had a lot to convey with just his
body and facial expressions while using
no words he needed to show the audience
that he wasn't human he was an eternal
being who spent his every fiber holding
all these universes dreams together
that's a lot of pressure with no
dialogue i did work very hard hopefully
to create an image that would tell an
audience that story with no words number
three the realm of lucifer morningstar
the vfx team spent more time on this
episode than any other episode there are
so many incredible practical effects the
gate for example is an actual sculpture
at first they didn't even know if they
should show the set on screen bfx
supervisor ian markowitz tells dan of
geek anything that we show of lucifer's
palace is going to be disappointing no
matter what it is no matter how cool it
is whatever we show is going to be a
little underwhelming but it turned out
to be their most rewarding episode they
ended up utilizing real-life images like
the vatican and a specific cathedral in
milan as inspiration number four so much
was actually built practically our art
department are set decorators our
production designers they are wizards it
was really important to neil gaiman and
the rest of the show's creators that
whenever they could create or build
something they would do it there's
actually not a ton of cgi in the show
compared to what you might think they
even had a real raven on set it didn't
speak unfortunately but tom did get to
interact with a real live bird having a
raven there was amazing just something
like you're talking it's like
number five who else is a fan of
despair's crocs for starters jenna
coleman's character joanna went through
almost a dozen different costume
iterations before they landed on her
iconic trench coat look also i got
really over excited about having a
crucifix in my boot for tom sturvig's
costume design they also went through a
few different looks at first he just
wanted to be as true to the comic book
character as he could get and i wanted
my hair to be wild and i wanted my eyes
to be as dark as night but obviously
that's not the dream we ended up with
neil will agree with me is i looked
ridiculous they ended up sticking with
tom's more natural luck as they found
that to be a better fit for the screen
number six we've gotta talk about
matthew considering they really wanted
to take a mostly practical effect with
this show they definitely wanted their
cgi to be as top-notch as possible ian
markowitz shared his story in creating
matthew with den of geek it is probably
the most successful cg feather bird that
i've seen on film or television and
that's saying a lot because we had a
photo real aspiration for something that
was known the thing was either going to
look like a real bird or it wasn't
matthew not only had to look real but he
had to fly move and interact with the
rest of the cast considering he was once
human himself they had to create facial
expressions that resembled natural human
emotion not a simple task
number seven we're all familiar with the
famous john constantine that's the
reason why he's not in the show neil
thought he'd been represented enough in
the media so he pitched the idea to
allen about turning him into joanna we
both thought about jenna and jenna's
voice and that went a long way just in
terms of my conception of who she was
they wanted to do a fresh spin on the
character so they took what they loved
about jon and brought new life into it
and we just had a lot of fun i think um
on all fronts number eight there were
several sandman movie and television
pitches that didn't work over the years
neil gaiman always felt passionate about
bringing sandman to life but only if it
could be done in the right way he told
ign i didn't care about it getting made
i would so much rather that it never got
made then a bad version would get made
even a director he really respects eric
kripke pitched a sandman series for
network tv in 2010 neil gaiman had many
reservations about that at the time the
damage that you had to do to sandman to
put it on network tv 15 years ago and in
the kind of budgets and the way that you
could do it just meant it wasn't sandman
number nine if you'd read the comics
you'd know how well they pulled this off
when filming the show they really wanted
as many scenes as they could manage to
be like you pulled it straight off the
page what was really thrilling was
remembering how accurately some of those
frames were replicated they always had a
copy of the graphic novel right next to
the camera that was so important to us
when we were making number ten ian
markowitz definitely had his hands full
here something really beautiful but also
incredibly difficult about the show was
that every episode is different from the
one before it with dream being the only
thing holding the timeline together ian
shares his experience working on the
show's wide range of sets it's not a
procedural where we're doing similar
things next week there's always
something that's going to be different
about the next episode and dream may not
be on screen for every frame of the show
but he is always going to be at the
heart of things
number 11 not even his original comics
or panels from 1989 we're talking about
the scripts he wrote for artists before
any of that even got onto the page when
ian markowitz was brought on as the vfx
supervisor he found the project to be a
bit daunting at first because of how
well known the world of sandman already
was he describes having been given
neil's notes as being gifted gold he
explains i thought that starting with
neil's notes was the perfect way for us
to think about adapting the show because
sometimes the comic book panel is very
comic booky and it has that wild quirky
zany quality which i don't think the
show has all of that much
number 12 not only did tom sturridge go
through it with his look but he also had
to mentally prepare to become the
eternal being that is morpheus neil gave
him some pertinent advice on how dream
carries himself he has thought every
thought that could ever be thought or
could ever be conceived of with every
line he said he had to utilize his voice
to convey that message to us therefore
when he speaks
it should feel as if it's etched in
stone number 13 if anyone can do it neil
gaiman can neil gaiman what's the key
the sandman comics were first released
over three decades ago but the cult
following has remained extremely
dedicated it makes sense that a casual
dinner conversation between neil gaiman
alan heinberg and david goyer would lead
to a netflix pitch three days later
honestly that sort of felt like okay
well it feels like it would be a tv
first season number fourteen they
actually had the cast before the writing
was even finished allen heinberg was
extremely grateful that the sandman
already had such a massive following
they were able to cast for it pretty
much immediately having the cast at hand
was highly preferred as allen likes to
write with the actor's voice in mind one
of the characters that went through the
most transformation on the page was
corinthian neil and i decided you know
what we're going to embrace everything
that void is boyd holbrook being cast
completely changed the way they
approached the character and there was a
version of that within with everybody in
the cast number 15 there has to be at
least one there are so many incredible
characters with stories worth following
when talking about the end of sandman it
makes it much easier for the showrunners
to see the end when you have source
material you're going off of but
something unknown that excites them are
all the potential series they could
create from other characters there are
death miniseries we'd love to explore
doing there are other characters worthy
of having their own adventures so after
going through the practical set designs
comic book replicas costumes and neil
gaiman's vintage sandman scripts were
still completely floored by all the
incredible talent and dedication it took
to bring this series to life what were
you most excited to see on screen
[Music]